[Musique]
des immeubles éventrés
calcinés ici à bord awdian qu'à une
heure de kiev plus de 700 appartements
ont été détruits
les lions ont été sécurisés les experts
sont passés pour évaluer les dommages
mais jusqu'à quand ces bâtiments
tiendront-ils debout
reconstruire est désormais la priorité
les kicks aux doigts en deux ou trois
semaines ils ont détruit non seulement
les immeubles mais aussi la vie
aujourd'hui
borodianka est prêt pour débuter le
processus de rénovation mais nous avons
besoin de matériel de reconstruction
c'est demain de voulons que les
habitants qui ont fui puisse revenir
mais ils n'ont malheureusement aucun
endroit où vivre
90 % de la population a fui la ville
pendant l'occupation russe la moitié
seulement a décidé de rentrer depuis
début juin certains habitants lochte ici
dans ces préfabriqués financé par la
pologne une aide plus que bienvenu pour
anna et son mari
va sûrement nous sommes vraiment
reconnaissants pour ça merci au
gouvernement polonais et à toutes les
personnes qui prennent soin de nous et à
tous les bénévoles
le centre d'hébergement peut accueillir
350 personnes beaucoup comme un avons
devoir y rester des mois peut-être même
des années
entre et s'il vous plaît
de chez elle ne reste plus rien mais
anna garde le sourire elle est en vie
regardez nous vivions là au quatrième
étage là c'était notre balcon
vous voyez il y avait un escalier
regarder sur la photo suivante
il s'est effondré
depuis notre chambre vous tombez dans le
vide
bombardements aériens bombardements
depuis la rue le centre-ville de
borodianka n'a pas été épargné par les
russes quand vous arrivez ici vous vous
rendez compte de l'ampleur des dégâts la
reconstruction prendra des années et ce
alors que le pays est toujours en guerre
les destructions se comptent par
milliers dans tout le pays à millas à
une trentaine de kilomètres de kiev des
volontaires se mobilisent pour déblayer
le dernier étage de cet immeuble il a
été entièrement détruite dans un
bombardement
je suis de gijon j'ai passé 50 jours
sous occupation russe j'ai réussi à fuir
il ya un mois et demi une partie de ma
famille se trouve toujours là-bas fut
ici je n'ai pas d'argent on y travaille
mais j'ai envie d'aider mon pays comment
puis-je faire
je peux faire ça en nettoyant ces débris
dans des endroits comme ça
hall est ici accompagnée de sa voisine a
fui le quartier avec sa femme et sa
fille la veille du bombardement
il habitait au cinquième étage
deux tirs de chars ont touché cette
pièce
l'incendié a tout détruit
voyez ici c'est là où dormait notre
petite fille
on a été visé ici aussi
une partie du plafond qui s'est écroulé
a été réparée mais l'appartement reste
inhabitable en l'état
les habitants de l'immeuble se sont
cotisés pour financer les travaux du
bâtiment
c'est pour que l'immeuble ne soit pas
inondée par la pluie et la neige parce
qu elques et les aides de l'état ne nous
seront versés que dans un an si elles le
sont la guerre est toujours au coude
à quelques kilomètres de millas à dmitry
fca ce sont les autorités de la région
de kiev qui coordonne les travaux de
reconstruction
les dons viennent pour l'essentiel
d'entreprise de bâtiments
cinq maisons ont déjà été reconstruite
quinze autres devraient suivre
[Musique]
reconstruire tous les bâtiments nous
avons besoin de plus de 30 millions de
dollars des réparations de cette ampleur
sont impossibles si on ne fait appel
qu'à des bénévoles
mais nous sommes limités par la question
de savoir où et comment obtenir des faux
plus de vingt-quatre mille kilomètres de
routes ont été endommagées depuis le
début de la guerre trois cent ponts ont
été détruits
l'ukraine a déjà réparé ce qu'elle a pu
mais le chantier reste immense et elle a
besoin d'argent le pays espère pouvoir
compter notamment sur l'aide de l'europe
la facture est colossal
le calcul est cette estimation augmente
chaque jour il y en a pour plus de 100
milliards de dollars
il est impossible d'imaginer
reconstruire l'ukraine sans aucune aide
extérieure et nexans
et bien sûr nous voudrions que la russie
est pour sa part ce qu'ils sont venus
dans notre pays
ou endommager nos infrastructures
détruit nos villes une doivent payer
mais saisir les avoirs russes sera
compliqué juridiquement est loin d'être
suffisant pour reconstruire le pays tant
que la guerre ne sera pas terminée la
facture continuera d'augmenter